ich weiß nicht ob du weißt wo du hier
eigentlich heute bist wir sind in bayern
und du kommst ohne tracht ich dachte ich
schon mal die ein oder andere tracht
gleich heute hier von dir ab liebe
corinna mann du bist ja hier ordentlich
gewandet angekündigt war rot grünen aber
jetzt ganz in rot mit einem dezenten
ausschnitt unter dem kinn schick
hintergrund der ganzen sache ist immer
ich sag immer lieber rot als kleidung am
körper als rot in der regierung ja so
oder auf dem bundesplatz vize
präsidenten stuhl 8 claudia wir haben
uns überlegt bei der rad schlagen
unseres kleinen bühnenprogramms unter
welches motto wir eigentlich so unsere
22 zufolge stellen und haben überlegt
wir standen ja bis letzten sonntag ein
schritt vom abgrund dann kam die bahn in
hamburg dann standen wir im abgrund 70
prozent linke abgeordnete in der
hamburger bürgerschaft und deswegen
haben wir gesagt auch nach den
reaktionen auf unser wahlmanöver in
thüringen
wir sollten wir das heute nennen ich
würde sagen deutschland auf links
gedreht oder wie man mit inkompetenz
erfolgreich politik macht groß
[Applaus]
ich hatte bevorzugt das motto dummheit
war noch nie so mächtig greifbar und
bunt aber ist unterscheidet sich nicht
wesentlich
ich muss zunächst mal sagen ist
natürlich jetzt nicht einfach so einer
aschermittwochsrede vorzubereiten
normalerweise bei der aschermittwoch
immer dafür gedacht so richtig politisch
und auch mental und auch mal so ein
bisschen schlüpfrig die sau rauszulassen
wer denkt da nicht angst randstein
legendäre franz josef strauß reden dass
stephan botschen die eine oder andere
genannt das ist natürlich vorbei liebe
freunde meinungsfreiheit in deutschland
ist nur noch eine hohle phrase sondern
aschermittwochsrede wird zum ritt auf
der rasierklinge
ich glaube die presse ist auch nicht
daher weil sie jetzt besonders objektiv
über uns zu berichten wir sondern die
erwarten einen skandal corinna von uns
sexismus rassismus gegen solche sachen
werden wahrscheinlich erwartet wir
werden sie aber enttäuschen
da muss man mal irgendwie so vorbei dann
haben wir die antifa die erwartet zwar
nichts weil sie kapiert ja nix die
prügeln und grün und wollen ich weiß
nicht einmal aufgefallen ist sie wollen
immer irgendwie verkünden da ist was
schief gelaufen in der entwicklung der
antifa manier des fck ich dachte immer
das werk kaiserslautern aber das heißt
tatsächlich ein wert ohne und sie denken
immer nur an sex wenn sie über die afg
reden ich verstehe das gar nicht also
ich finde das ziemlich anmaßend muss ich
sagen sogar in meinem alter kann ich das
nicht mehr angemessen schließlich antifa
die warten darauf dass sie irgendwas
passiert und dann natürlich der
staatsanwalt wissen alles und jeder von
der afg wird heutzutage angezeigt liegen
alles und jeden und jeder dieser
veranstaltung und ich habe jetzt ein
strafgesetz nochmal durchgeschaut da
müssen wir jetzt auch noch durch ich hab
davon die paragraphen 80 bis 82
strafgesetzbuch 90 bis 91 108 bis 104
111 strafgesetzbuch 130 strafgesetzbuch
166 strafgesetzbuch 185 ford folgende
strafgesetzbuch da müssen wir heute
durch aber ich glaube wir schaffen das
wir müssen sagen so zu programmieren
dass sie im vorwort dass ich mir dachte
herauszunehmen
da müssen wir natürlich auch damit
aufräumen das ist jetzt nicht die quoten
frau an meiner seite und ich mache das
ja auch nicht freiwillig die koreaner
hat gesagt wir müssen das zusammen
machen stefan und wenn man die korinther
das dach dann muss man dem natürlich
folgen deshalb stehe ich hier gerne
vielen dank für die einladung corinna
hast du beute bayern sagen bei der
stiftstraße darauf ungehindert wollte
thüringer ich war ja auch schon mal
beute bayer
ich war stefan du bist du ich bin auf
nordrhein-westfalen 1990 geflüchtet auf
dem roten nordrhein-westfalen und heute
immer in das gelobte land und das
gelobte land war für mich bayern liebe
freunde
da bin ich dann hingekommen 1990 und war
glücklich 1990 bis 96 und war ja dabei
zwischen muss ich sagen bin ich in
thüringen und das land ist eigentlich
noch gelobter inzwischen als neuer
bayern aber ihr seid auf einem guten weg
es wieder zum gelobten dann zu machen
es ist die stimmung so ein bisschen
runter wöchentlich corinna ich kann das
ja mit stefan und jede anteil vor allen
dingen meinen eigenen sender und sie
wissen prolog stefan jetzt meistens
länger als die ganze sendung aber
geschenkt schlagen wir mal ein in unsere
bestandsaufnahme in deutschland auf
links gedreht ein themenfeld was ich
immer anbietet ist die bundeswehr eine
bestandsaufnahme zu sagen alltag
bundeswehr claudia roth ralf stegner
nichts noch nichts funktioniert ist es
nicht wer fähig ohne wehrpflicht kaum
tauglich soldaten t5 ist ja heutzutage
gar kein ausmusterung sgr und mehr
sondern ausweis von grundsätzlicher
trainierbar kite aber wir haben ja nicht
mal tauglicher uniform bis auf die für
schwangere brauchen wir auch ganz
dringend genauso wie die bundeswehr
werdende mütter auch immer stärker
braucht schließlich muss der grad der
buntheit relativ groß erfüllt sein
aber wenn man das machen will dann
sollte man vielleicht konsequent einfach
auch mal den ersten rosen panzer bringen
ja sogar einen konkreten vorschlag
folgten
ich hab fachkompetenz es kommt
eigentlich noch also und wie wäre es den
teuren schützenpanzer den neuen puma um
zu lackieren
dann kann man die nämlich für die frauen
hernehmen in dem rosa panzer und werden
da kein platzproblem er ja hinten
konnten ja nur die männer bis 184 sitzen
das problem ist dann weg der wagen
gehört der verein würde sich totlachen
also wer auch schon einiges dann an
erfolge erzielt der wusste lacht sich
tot wenn sie eine rosa panzer auf die
zukunft haben wir einen die kindersitze
gedacht im truppentransporter kannst du
dich vielleicht besser aus also müssen
wir auch daran denken so
das war jetzt davids oder jetzt ob ich
nach 110 80 bin ich dran nee freunde
bundeswehr hochmotivierte soldaten ist
tut mir das immer so ein bisschen leid
das thema wir haben hoch motivierte
soldaten die im ausland ihren mann
stehen ihr leben jeden tag aufs spiel
setzen für uns für für unser deutschland
aber sie sind natürlich absolut tief
mütterlich behandelt wir haben material
das schließlich wir haben material es
fährt nicht wir haben material das
fliegt nicht bis auf zehn flugzeuge habe
ich gelesen soll funktionierende
deutschland wir haben material das
schwimmt nicht bis auf die u boote die
schwimmen zwar aber die können wiederum
nicht tauchen die helikopter die
helikopter sind technisch flugbereit
konnten aber nicht abgeben weil die
betriebsanleitung fehlt das ist alles
ganz traurig was in deutschland hier
passiert und das hat irgendwas mit
frauen zu tun oder
ja denn wir müssen natürlich auch mal
ein bisschen die schuldigen benennen wir
erinnern uns daran so dieses eine frauen
du das zusammen bei den feierlichkeiten
zum offiziellen stabwechsels mit
militärischen ehren durch peinliches
händchenhalten auffiel sie erinnern sich
die hanni und nanni aus dem
verteidigungsministerium
ursula von der leyen und annegret kramp
karrenbauer und natürlich müssen wir uns
da auch ein bisschen einzelnen daran
abarbeiten deswegen stefan was hast du
denn zur flinte noch schlitten ski oder
ursel ich bin nämlich ganz sicher ich
verwechsle dass man mal so ein bisschen
flinken brüssel hat sich ja
damals wirklich vom acker gemacht dann
nachdem sie die bundeswehr in den
schlamm geritten hat sag ich mal hat sie
sich locker vom acker gemacht und hat
sich ganz demokratisch küren lassen zur
was ist denn geworden
eu-kommissionspräsident in sowas nicht
kandidiert typisch wurde aber gewählt
ganz demokratisch da wo du bist ja auch
nicht rückgängig macht muss ich sagen
ganz anders als in thüringen wo jemand
gewählt wurde der auch zur wahl stand
[Applaus]
auf der anderen seite hatten wir einen
kandidaten das ist derjenige der jetzt
oben wenig und unten fiel ja das ist
jetzt also auf dem kopf traf martin
schulz jetzt das hat sich nicht zu
seinem vorteil verändert ja also wenn
man wenn man der weber man ihn lieber
money stand zur wahl hatte eigentlich
auch für relativ schön viele stimmen auf
sich vereinigt aber das wurde dann
offenbar rückgängig gemacht aus dem
kanzleramt das wollte man nicht so ernst
nehmen und das gesagt kommt die flinten
ursel bundeswehr der
untersuchungsausschuss ist kritisch die
entsorgen oder nein
die lage war mal inzwischen die daten
lagern damit zwischen die lagern wenn
man in brüssel zwischen und schauen mal
was daraus wird flynn mosel was macht
sie in brüssel jetzt wohl sie macht
jetzt das klima kaputt und europa oder
das anders kann sie ja nicht
es kommt eine rechnung irgendwie rechnen
sie also wir tippen mal sieht ja all die
kämpferinnen ja erst hat sie sich an der
bundeswehr abgearbeitet und sie fast
besiegt muss man sagen
und jetzt jetzt jetzt ist das klima dran
ja bitte mal wenn man mal so ein
bisschen rechnen auf 50% ausgaben für
berater 50 prozent für freunde und dann
nochmal 50 prozent für klimaschädliche
maßnahmen machte 150 nein ich habe mich
nicht verrechnet die rechnet wirklich so
es heißt natürlich der nächste
untersuchungsausschuss wird dann auf
kommissions- auf eu-ebene dann nicht
lange auf sich warten lassen aber musste
fleißig aber mit ihrer handy sachen der
anderen hanni und nanni also wir haben
noch jemand ak khk da gibt es ja die
ganz schön abkürzungen was du hast du
immer alle last kleiner clown ja an dem
gerät kann kanzler das ist natürlich
jetzt geschichte
ja die dame aus dem saarland ich weiß
gar nicht was ich hatte auch einen
charismatischen nachfolger einem sein
dann muss man auch mal sagen den
ministerpräsidenten weiß gar nicht wie
der heißt aber aus dem saarland
es gibt da bittet ministerpräsidenten in
thüringen übrigens auch aber nur den
also aus dem saarland kam sie irgendwie
so manche war nur bekannt aus
irgendwelchen noch missglückten
carnevals auftreten wie jetzt wir hier
beide hinlegen und damit ist wurde sie
entweder wie auch nach berlin gespült
und dann hat sie gesagt auf keinen fall
ins kabinett merkel
das war also ein dogma für acker kam was
passierte dann betrat sie doch ins
kabinett merkel ein und hat also den
vernichtungs zug dass unsere bundeswehr
angeht fortgesetzt und setzt ihn doch
fort die tradition sie steht ja in
tradition mal wir haben viele zuerst mal
aufgefallen
wir haben viele hochrangige politiker
aus dem kleinen saarland
da fällt uns ein heiko maas
also ich hätte zunächst an erich
honecker gedacht na ja da habe ich auch
wieder historisch historisch korrekt
vorgehen erich honecker das ist schon
mal richtig also akg aber auch saarland
wer waffen die der war völlig schon beim
saarland ist aber so ganz links aus in
deutschland kurz vor
kurz vor schlagen gleich also der
honecker wir haben ein charismatiker wie
heiko maas heiko maas nicht übel aber
wenn heiko maas sieht dann weiß man
warum im wort minister mini drinsteckt
dollar
ich habe ja gesagt zu groß zu klein für
jeden anzug und zu klein für das
politische amt das ist heiko maas sein
gegen polen zumindest was den anzug
angeht ist ein anderer saarländer mainz
1 1 meier
genau da sieht das mit dem anzug ganz
anders aussah gemahl der sitzt ja immer
wie reingepresst oder wir wollten
aufpassen was du sagst dann ziehe ich
mich dafür ja dass irgendwas in
verbindung gebracht bei dem nicht
verbinden in verbindung gebracht werden
willst also was wir sagen wollen ist
eigentlich dass das saarland kennt kein
mensch aber kommen doch sehr viele
führende politiker her und zwar aller
couleur und auch alle ausmaß aber wer
wird jetzt der eigentlich der nächste
wer wird eigentlich der nächste
wehrbeauftragte da gab es noch eine
ankündigung
ich glaube jetzt alles gut das hat man
ja öfter mal wehrbeauftragte gehabt die
gar nicht bei der bundeswehr waren und
jetzt am horizont zeichnet sich ein
oberst der reserve ab weingut werden
oder du geholfen
[Applaus]
ja dann kannst du natürlich das aber
nicht hier
es gibt doch kein gutes ende denn dieser
oberst der reserve soll tatsächlich
johannes hass macht hässlich cars sein
er hat sich doch in den letzten
haushaltsverhandlungen also er hat als
haushaltsexperte dem wehrbeauftragten
vielmehr stellen vier stellen mehr
zugeschanzt alle haben sich schon
gewundert der wehrbeauftragte wollte
diese stellen überhaupt nicht hatte gar
nichts dazu gesagt in jeder mannschaft
die schon ab sprungbrett in die
verwaltung ich halte das wenn ich mir so
anschaue und so seine vita mir vor augen
für für durchaus glaubwürdig ja also wir
müssen sagen ich habe mir echt gedacht
da kommt ein designierter ehemaliger
offizier ein offizier verdienst eine
oberst wir wissen alle helmut schmidt
war nur ein leutnant da kann man ja was
erwarten
und da kommt johannes kahrs stichwort
hass macht hässlich schauen sie mal im
spiegel genau das hat er uns gesagt und
wir uns aber wir haben uns gefragt haben
wir sie auch
aber es ist nicht aufzuhalten der mann
mit dem nazi tourette der mann der noch
schlechtere laune hat als sein
parteikollege hannes stegner gehört soll
das heißen da darf sich auch die truppe
freuen
übrigens johannes kahrs steht noch in
zusammenhang mit etwas ganz anderem
viele haben sich die zeitung gelesen
comic skandal
warum das in hamburg niemand im
hinterkopf hatte bei der wahl am sonntag
da verzichtet mal eben die hamburger
finanzbehörde auf 50 millionen euro von
der warburg-bank und hinterher kommt
dann raus also es gab dann aber
zwischenzeitlich auch ein paar spenden
an die spd in hamburg aber interessiert
niemanden
deswegen schon gelesen ein spd hat sich
über johannes kahrs soll sich geäußert
haben
da wo die kacke am dampfen ist johannes
kahrs nicht fairen hat irgendjemand mal
gesagt mach ich mir natürlich nicht zu
eigen aber ich glaube da ist was dran
wir denken auch an seinen [ __ ]
tweed immer ganz wieder gerne zurück und
so ne das ist eine gestandene
persönlichkeit und gerold entschuldigung
offenbar auch ein oberst der reserve
aber das kann der bundeswehr kann auch
was schief gehen manchmal ja gut bringt
so hamburg nach jetzt wissen wir
wenigstens wo die leute wohnen die die
spd wirklich über die 5 prozent schwelle
halten bundesweit alle in hamburg das
händlernetz zu sein
spd spd für uns immer noch die abkürzung
für schlechteste partei deutschlands
[Applaus]
manche sagen auch scharia partei
deutschlands finde ich auch sehr nett
und aktuelle schrumpfte partei
deutschland das passt doch nicht das
trifft den nagel auf den kopf
deswegen ist es an der zeit sich mit dem
spezial demokraten und den protagonisten
die dann noch auf der großen bühne so
rumturnen ein stück weit auseinander zu
setzen
die haben doch stefan jetz so politiker
pärchen ausgerufen
doch damit angefangen das haben sie uns
nach gemacht glaube ich nur wenn ich ein
weibchen also herzbube und herzdame
irgendwie sowas in diese richtung wäre
damit angefangen olaf scholz sind kennt
der ein oder andere vielleicht noch
unser finanzminister hatte eine dame
besucht den parteivorsitz und hatte
gefunden habe den namen hier klara
geywitz eine frau gefunden
was passierte dann dann hat ein anderer
gesucht abgekürzt sage ich immer nova bo
norbert walter borjans hat eine frau
gesucht und erfand saskia esken
so aber ich würde ganz toll ich würde
ganz toll wie es immer so unheimlich
begeistert von sich selbst und das in
voller bescheidenheit und jetzt mal ganz
ehrlich wenn es ein ausweis politischer
begabung ist immer genau zu denen themen
zu sprechen von denen man gar keine
ahnung hat dann ist die frau wirklich
hochbegabt trends so wussten sie zum
beispiel an silvester dass die polizei
die linken in leipzig connewitz ihr
wisst leipzig connewitz doch meinst das
singt und lacht leipzig connewitz das
brennt und 8 das ist die anti war die
daraus und die hat sich natürlich
leichter zu verstehen zu sagen die
polizei hat provoziert und sie wusste
natürlich auch sich zu wort zu melden
und tom buhrow dafür zu tadeln dass er
im gec umwelt sau gate davon reden wir
es hat sich doch mal lieber vor seine
mitarbeiter stellen sollte als sich
öffentlich für dieser groteske fehlen
leistung zu entschuldigen
außerdem hat die frau die sich übrigens
ständig mit irgendetwas zu wort melden
steuersenkungen zuletzt für gefährlich
war als gefährlich eingestuft und
deswegen hat man sich im internet jetzt
auf die schippe genommen ich weiß nicht
ob es einige gesehen haben bei facebook
man es kommt man kann gucken
es gibt jetzt hashtags kenzinger
aufgrund ihrer zahllosen entgleisung man
hat also bekannte kinofilme umgetextet
und so reden wir jetzt von steuerzahlen
wohnung das leben der anderen und
enteigne mich an einem anderen tag
aber es gibt ja auch eine stern über
saskia es geht los mit bekommen und ihre
ihre freundinnen und parteigenosse sind
klara geywitz lohfelden schulen erwähnt
hast sagt ja dass es unfair die frau
essen kriegt nur so viel schelte weil
sie eine frau ist
ist das nicht erwiesen
da war doch was machen wir sind die afd
ich darf hier ohne frauenquote vorne
mitmachen und du auch das ding so aber
wir haben so ein bisschen zu dem pärchen
entfernt wir hatten doch olaf scholz und
klara geywitz namen gesagt guck mal der
schulzeiten der frau gefunden
dann hatten wir norbert walter borjans
und dann gesagt gut der hat immerhin die
dass die ersten gefunden
dann machen die cdu machen ja jetzt mit
gesuchen ja auch pärchen rückgang ist
auf der suche habe ich gelesen märz hat
auch gesagt die nächste person an meiner
seite so eine frau sein
und laschet wurde schon für mich er hat
seinen spaß
[Applaus]
hab ich so gesehen kommt sind ja es war
zwar jetzt glückwunsch an dieser stelle
wir wünschen eine lange und innige
verbindung den beiden jetzt speziell
oder das kannst du nicht so stefan wir
kommen zu einem weiteren punkt wie sich
jetzt bei der bundeswehr durch haben uns
gemerkt dass eine spd abgearbeitet da
gibt es noch mehr leute an denen man
sich abarbeiten kann
und auch an den themen und ein assist
steuern und finanzierung aus der spd
jetzt auf keinen lockout dabei nicht
woher das kommt auch mal ganz klar die
kommt nach da habe ich auch etwas von
briefen nicht zu ende gelesen ja aber
sie blieb also eigentlich normalerweise
reicht das dass die leute auf den
tischen tanzen
ich distanziere mich davon was bruder
über sie geschrieben dass ich noch mal
zum besten geben oder kennen wir alle
nicht meine worte ich zitiere es nur und
machte sogleich wieder rücken nicht
vorschieben
mit dem integrierten
intelligenzquotienten einer birkenstock
sandalen gepaart mit dem charme einer
handbetriebenen kaffeemühle
ich weiß nicht was ich danach getrachtet
hat ich also ich mache mir nicht zu
eigen ich wollte noch mal ich wollte es
nicht um gesagt lassen
er war
[Applaus]
er ist echt nichts zu blöd nicht der
bruder ist so gar nicht schlecht ich mal
nicht am ruder
aber wir waren beim thema steuer und
reduzierung und da müssen wir das schöne
zuerst es gibt mehr geld für den staat
die co2 steuer ist da und wir können uns
das leisten in diesem wunderschönen land
in dem wir so gut und gerne leben und
geht es so gut wie nie zuvor
und das schöne ist wir haben ja auch
noch überschüsse im staat erwirtschaftet
ja das ist mein stichwort
da gehe ich immer an die decke wenn ich
höre der staat hat überschüsse
erwirtschaftet nein der staat
erwirtschaftet gar nichts wir alle
erwirtschaften jeden tag und der staat
nimmt uns weg und wenn der staat am ende
einer abrechnungsperiode zu viel geld in
der kasse hat man hat das war dann aber
zurück zu geben an diejenigen die zu
viel gezahlt werden der staat
erwirtschaftet keine überschüsse genauso
wenig wie der bankräuber einen
überschuss erwirtschaftet dadurch dass
er geld klaut um in der tüte voll geld
aus der bank heraus rennt der hat auch
in seiner tüte natürlich einen
überschuss aber das gehört ihm noch
lange nicht
sehr geehrte freunde der freien meinung
liebe freunde und überaus mutige
mitstreiter der alternativen für
deutschland hinter uns liegt hamburg vor
uns liegt ganz deutschland wir dürfen
sagen glück auf die bei hamburg schnell
raus trompetete lüge wie er seinen
rausch unter fünf prozent war kurz lebe
ich lügen haben kurze beine
wie kurz bemisst sich seit dem neuesten
nach ard und zdf sendeminuten gemäß der
alten wilhelm busch weisheit dass nicht
sein kann was nicht sein darf dass wir
nämlich drin wären jubel jubel wurde
bewusst fehlinformiert diese mit clown
ich danke dir und zähnen festgehaltene
wunsch informationen wurde zur
kurzweiligen lüge besonders schäbig weil
sie auch noch aufrechterhalten und
gesendet wurde
während die bürger im netz sich schon
über das statistische wahlamt hamburg
über die wahrheit längst informieren
konnten dass die afb drin ist also aus
der traum der anti demokraten vom abgang
der einzelne oppositionspartei die afd
ist hier um zu bleiben
ja es ist also drin dazu passend erhalte
ich hier eine eilmeldung aus dem
kanzleramt
die kanzlerin lässt mitteilen sollten
sich diese unverzeihlichen tendenzen
bestätigen müsse das wahlergebnis
unverzüglich rückgängig gemacht werden
und angeblich tönte lindner dass sich
jetzt mit fdp raus und af der ein die
prognose voll umdrehe das sei wieder so
wie in erfurt einer dieser politischen
taschenspielertricks der afd meine damen
und herren
unerhört aber liebe freunde wir müssen
auch ein paar ernstere töne anschlagen
dieser tage
es hat ein furchtbares ereignis gegeben
in hanau das ereignis in sich spottet
jeder beschreibung in seiner
schrecklichkeit wir müssen aber auch
darüber reden wie darüber geredet wurde
es ist ja so wenn ein kind von einem
schutzsuchenden vor einen icd gestoßen
und getötet wird ein mädchen von einem
asylbewerber vergewaltigt und ermordet
wird da hört man stets nur wir dürfen
die tat nicht verallgemeinern wir dürfen
die tat nicht instrumentalisieren am
ende war es dann ein psychisch labiler
traumatisierter täter oder bloß eine
beziehungstat wenn aber wie in hanau ein
psychisch schwer gestörter täter der
nach jahrelangen verfolgungswahn amok
läuft dann fahren gewisse deutsche
politiker ihre hetze gegen vermeintliche
verantwortliche in rekordzeit hoch und
das obwohl die tatsache dass dieser irre
auf freiem fuß war und waffen besaß das
ist doch das eigentliche staatsversagen
der hatte sich beim generalbundesanwalt
gemeldet mit seinem irrsinn prüfe ich
doch was das für einer ist
er war ein gefährlicher psychopath hat
seine seinen tötungs drang seine warnen
fantasien versucht zu rationalisieren
mit widerlichen rechtsextremistischen
rassistischen parolen aber das war ein
wirklich geisteskranker der sich seit
kindesbeinen von geheimdiensten in
seinem kopf verfolgt fühlte und der
wollte laut seinem manifest seine
paranoia ausleben durch auslöschung von
20 völkern und danach noch per
zeitmaschine wollte er an den frühen
planeten erde fliegen und alles leben
auslöschen für unsere politischen gegner
ist klar das sind originalzitate aus dem
afd parteiprogramm natürlich und diese
widerliche verleumdung liebe freunde wir
trauern um die opfer
wir wollen sie nicht missbraucht sehen
politisch und ich sage dieser amoklauf
der lüge der im nachhinein auch noch
stattgefunden hat das ist hier die
größte bedrohung für deutschland und
seine demokratie
denn die art des wahren täters wird
natürlich beeinflusst durch die
beherrschenden gesellschaftspolitischen
themen früher ging es um die serie im
kalten krieg kgb die stasi ein arzt
berichtet dass ein schizophrener patient
sich mal vom kgb kontrolliert und
verfolgt fühlte so dass er schließlich
seinen dackel für einen geschickt
verkleideten kgb spitze hielt das kostet
in diesen dackel leider das leben
allerdings hält jetzt niemand den man
für einen tierquäler und ich kann ihnen
sagen ist es auch nicht die sowjetische
regierung im nachhinein für diese tat
verantwortlich gemacht worden
deshalb diejenigen die bei jedem
islamistischen anschlag zur besonnenheit
aufrufen und das mantra der psychisch
verwirrten einzeltäters runterbeten die
wären hier auf den plan gerufen wo
wirklich mal ein isolierter ihrer um
sich ballert und ein paranoides weltbild
mit rassistischem einschlag auslebt so
ist jeder versuch scharf zurückzuweisen
eine parlamentarisch agierende partei
die um demokratische mehrheiten ringt
die den bürger überzeugen will von einem
besseren politischen weg irgendwie in
verbindung zu bringen mit einem psycho
der mit unsichtbaren menschen spricht
laut seinem pamphlet und mit einer
zeitmaschine das entstehen der
menschheit verhindern will
das heißt hannover zeigt wir müssen auch
die linke deutungshoheit brechen wir
müssen die verleumdungskampagne der
altparteien und ihrer medialen clique
entschieden als solche entlarven es
kassiert nämlich inzwischen eine
gefährliche epidemie
meine damen und herren es müssen
vielleicht einzelne sendeanstalten
sollten abgeriegelt werden überall
schießen nämlich rechtsextremismus
experten aus dem boden das muss eine
ansteckende krankheit seien unter
arbeitslosen politologen und deshalb
warne ich davor dass deren ausbreitung
immer weiter politisiert
der lippe mörder schlimm eine schlimme
tat er war aber schon anfang der
neunziger als neonazi auffällig als ein
alexander gauland noch cdu politiker war
der täter in halle hat sich im
englischsprachigen internet was er auch
adressiert radikalisiert ob die tat von
hanau ist nicht ergebnis der politischen
diskussion der letzten jahre eben
vielmehr das ergebnis von einem der seit
langem in paranoiden wahnvorstellungen
lebt die gesamte menschheit ausrotten
wollte auch das deutsche volk der mal
bei einem banküberfall
den hat er miterlebt da war er
angestellter dann wurden ihm im
nachhinein ausländische täterprofile
mögliche gezeigt seitdem hat der typ
einen knacks weg dass es viele viele
viele jahre her das sind saud laut
seinem pamphlet das inzwischen nicht
mehr im internet erreichbar ist und die
leute die es versenden wollen werden
gesperrt die leute wollen nicht dass die
bürger die wahrheit lesen das ist der
hintergrund seiner radikalisierung
keiner von diesen tätern hat irgendwo
einen parlamentarisch diskursiven zugang
wie wir ihn pflegen in erwägung gezogen
dennoch sollen die afg plötzlich
verantwortlich sein das ist scheußlich
das ist eine schamlose argumentative
leichenfledderei der altparteien hetzer
von maximaler obszönität vor ihm meine
damen und herren
und was machen stattdessen die
staatlichen ordnungskräfte hier in
bayern der verfassungsgerichtshof hat
die 2016 in bayern eingeführte das
integrationsgesetz für verfassungswidrig
erklärt die vorgesehene verpflichtung
dort eine leitkultur zu vermitteln
sie verletze die rundfunkfreiheit und
ebenso sei ein verpflichtender grundkurs
über die werte der freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung für
migranten die diese ordnung ablehnten
ein unzulässiger eingriff in die
meinungsfreiheit was für ein wahnsinn
meine damen und herren und ebenfalls
schauen wir nach münchen was man bisher
von der führerscheinprüfung kannte dass
ausländer sich gegen bezahlung für
andere ausgeben um dann für die die
fahrprüfung zu machen das funktioniert
auch jetzt bei der deutschprüfung für
migranten in münchen gibt es also eine
vierköpfige deutschtest betrügerbande
die für 5000 euro mit gefälschten
ausweisen für migranten den deutschtest
ablegt allerdings gab es ein
unerwartetes problem
die betrüger konnten selbst nicht
richtig deutsch sie fielen regelmäßig
durch ich weiß nicht ob man dann sein
geld zurückbekommt allerdings kommt der
fall dadurch wenigstens rechtlich lieber
stefan wenigstens wieder in ordnung denn
der anwalt argumentierte da mein mandant
bei der prüfung durch viel kann von
professionellen banden strukturen nicht
die rede gewesen sein
wer könnte sich dieser zwingenden logik
entziehen
aber meine damen und herren es wurde
schon gesagt ich komme aus berlin
es war auch schon vom fliegen gerade wir
in berlin wollen ja dieses jahr einen
flughafen eröffnen und die
flughafengesellschaft vom br die checkt
jetzt nur noch die letzten
funktionsfähigkeit 'nen damit alles
glattgeht das ist eine wahre meldung
wurden 20.000 komparsen angeworben die
die eincheck vorgänger mal checken
sollen ob da alles rund läuft ich
vermute dass es ein geheimpapier gibt
dass diese verträge auch noch über den
eröffnungstermin im oktober hinaus in
dauerhaft
verträge umwandeln will zu dass
fortlaufend der anschein eines in
betrieb befindlichen flughafens
aufrechterhalten werden kann
whatever it takes nehme doch mal an es
gibt dann auch sonderzulagen für den in
letzter sekunde an den schalter rennen
passagiere wie ich nachher für den
passagier mit herzproblemen für die
ausländische familien mit kleinen
kindern es ist an alles gedacht es wird
absolut professionell aussehen in
thüringen geht es jetzt um eine
fanatische ausgrenzung ich vermute wir
stehen kurz davor dass im abgeordneten
restaurant extra geschirr für die
abgeordneten der raf de gibt vielleicht
auch eine extra sitzbank nur für die afg
und andere nicht für afd
können wir das nicht irgendwo her ja so
weit sind wir in diesem land das ist es
wohl wohin der weg führt ich hoffe doch
dass im abgeordneten restaurant die
brandmauer schon eingezogen worden ist
oder doch wenigstens prophylaktisch ein
roter kreidestrich warnend über den
boden gezogen wurde
damit man nicht in nähe zu diesen
verfemten abgeordneten kommt und wie die
leute umgehen mit denen die willig sind
noch vernunft zu bewahren zeigt der fall
vom ost beauftragten hirte der hatte
kemmerich gratuliert und der musste
zittern
ich zitiere die frau bundeskanzlerin hat
mir in einem gespräch mitgeteilt dass
ich nicht mehr beauftragter für die
neuen länder sein kann
ihre anregung folgend habe ich daher um
meine entlassung gebeten
diese cdu typische unterwürfigkeit orgie
das ist aller hat man mir mitgeteilt
dass ich nicht mehr mitglied der
lebenden sein kann
dieser anregung folgenden habe ich
deshalb um ein messer und einen kleinen
wand schirm gebeten hinter dem ich das
nötige vollziehen kann meine damen und
herren hirte hätte es gewiss opfer aber
hätte es gewiss opfer aber recht brav
jedenfalls so verinnerlicht man das in
der regenwurm partei denn sie wissen es
ja der regenwurm ist das wappentier der
union er besitzt kein rückgrat
er bewegt sich kriechend vorwärts
kriechend rückwärts ist schleimig zur
selbstverstümmelung fähig schnürt bei
bedarf eine reihe von werte unions
segmenten ab überlässt sie dem räuber
und flüchtet mit dem rest körper das
totem tier der union
[Applaus]
kubicki kubicki hatte es eine einem
lichten moment manchmal kubicki wirklich
licht im moment klar beschrieben statt
einer minderheitsregierung ramelow
einfach eine minderheitsregierung
kemmerich alles andere bleibt gleich
aber das war schon mehr vernunft als
schwarz-gelb verkraften kann und ein
linda ist seitdem auf entschuldung
stoney also auf selbstverleugnung stone
er habe unterschätzt dass die afg so
skrupellos ist einen fdp kandidaten zu
wählen
das ist skrupellos wenn man einen fdp
man wählt meine damen und herren man
könnte lachen wenn es nicht so tragisch
ist es wäre so einfach gewesen
cdu und fdp hätten nur ein paar wochen
das mediale sperrfeuer durchhalten
müssen um das land endlich aus links
grüner geiselhaft zu befreien aber
regierung und medien konnten diesen
befreiungsschlag nicht dulden
dafür wird die die fdp in hamburg jetzt
zurecht abgestraft für ihren wankelmut
für ihre feigheit ihre halbherzigkeit
ihren demokratie verrat vor
und genauso in der cdu
gucken sie uns die fraktionsvizes in
thüringen und sachsen anhalt an der
thüringische cdu fraktionsvize heim
sagte zu merkels einmischung zitat da
habe ich mich an tiefsten ddr-zeiten
erinnert gefühlt ist eine demokratische
wahl gewesen die nicht schlimm gewesen
sei auch er wurde zum rücktritt genötigt
bestrafe ein erzieher 100 so ist das in
der diktatorischen cdu partei wie könnte
eine partei eigentlich noch besser ihre
demokratie ferne gesinnung ihren
meinungs- unterdrückenden charakter
bezeugen als in dem sie jeden rauswirft
der ihr gerade das vorwirft das passiert
dort und deshalb sage ich dieser
abnickverein hat fertig den braucht
niemand mehr
und genauso der cdu-fraktionsvize von
sachsen-anhalt zimmer der muss jetzt
auch sein amt im landesvorstand ruhen
lassen er hat eine unions politiker
appelliert doch bitte den elfenbeinturm
zu verlassen und mal mit der basis zu
reden er sagte ich kann keine 25 prozent
wähler vor den kopf stoßen und sagen mit
euren vertretern rede ich nicht
jetzt gibt er sich zerknirscht und lässt
mitteilen
die von mir getätigten aussagen waren
geeignet dahingehend interpretiert zu
werden dass sie geltenden beschlüssen
der partei widersprechen was er
eigentlich sagen wollte
die von ihr getätigten aussagen waren
geeignet dahingehend interpretiert zu
werden dass es in der real union noch
realitätssinn gibt dass es dort noch
basisnähe gibt und meinungsfreiheit
vorhanden ist aber leider ist das ein
irrtum
und jetzt hat musste er deshalb auch
über den jordan ins tote gleis der
partei
das zeigt gerade im osten wo schon viele
erwacht sind diese cdu braucht niemand
mehr
aber die kanzlerin die kanzlerin weiß in
ihrer zur zweiten natur geworden in
diktatorischen anmaßung sofort was sie
sagt wenn sie eine normale demokratische
wahl als unverzeihlich geißelt
wohlgemerkt linda und kubicki fanden die
sache völlig okay waren erst erfreut
während die kanzlerin wie es heißt eine
äusserung verlauten ließ von mit
leichtem unbehagen in südafrika ich gebe
ihnen den ursprünglichen text bevor er
später regiert wurde im fernsehen wieder
der ursprüngliche text der kanzlerin
hieß also wenn ich mich jetzt noch dafür
entschuldigen soll dass sich
demokratische wahlen rückgängig machen
will dann ist das nicht mehr meine ddr
meine damen und herren das war der
urtext
ach ja ich höre gerade angela merkel ist
gestürzt sie war kurzzeitig nicht
ansprechbar
als sie wieder erwachte und über die
aktuelle lage informiert wurde meinte
sie die grenzöffnung durch günter
schabowski sei unverzeihlich und müsse
umgehend rückgängig gemacht werden und
meine damen und herren es ist auch so
wir im bundestag sind ja besonders nah
dran an den geschehnissen und im
bundestag wird jetzt etwas gemacht was
die zwei klassen sicherheit in diesem
land verdeutlicht er soll nämlich zur
festung ausgebaut werden mit einem
graben
das ist ein burggraben den mann erst
bemerkt wenn man kurz davor steht sie
laufen also voller bewunderung für das
monument der demokratie über den
reichstag rasen plötzlich sacken sie
zweieinhalb meter in die tiefe und sagen
sich aha hier war also einen graben
da kann man nur hoffen dass dann auch
endlich innerhalb der zitadelle mal ein
aha-erlebnis reif das effektiver
grenzschutz eben nötig ist und migration
kein naturereignis ist meine damen und
herren
dafür bräuchte man die bundespolizei und
an die bundespolizei hat man gedacht zur
besetzung von über 2000 planstellen hat
die bundespolizei ihre anforderungen an
bewerber gesenkt statt weitsprung und
liegestützen gibt es jetzt noch pendelt
auf und als mit 12 millionen euro
das alte rathaus in dresden zum
abschiebegefängnis für abgelehnte
asylbewerber umgebaut wurde inklusive
drei meter hohen zaun moderner
sicherheitstechnik was machten da zwei
tunesier und eine morgana während eines
hofgangs sie kletterten über den zaun
jetzt wird nach ihnen gefahndet merke
die wachleute waren nicht schnell genug
sie sind halt pendelt gelaufen stadt
hinterher so sieht's aus in deutschland
und man bereitet uns auch schon auf die
folgen der energiewende vor nämlich
stromausfälle das bundesamt für
katastrophenhilfe gibt jetzt ein notfall
kochbuch heraus für zeiten ohne so einen
technischen mittel kram wie
funktionierenden strom mit rezepten für
eine nahrhafte und schmackhafte mahlzeit
die man ohne elektrische küchengeräte
und sowas wie leitungswasser zubereiten
kann
vielleicht werden deshalb provisorisch
schon afrikanische fachkräfte hier
eingebracht die kennen sich aus
womöglich im kochen ohne strom und
wasser
ein fall für interkulturelle kompetenz
macht man das schon
hier entsteht womöglich eine neue
fachkräfte einwanderungs sparte speziell
auf leute zugeschnitten die eben
nahrhafte und schmackhafte speisen ohne
diese unnötigen co2 verursachen den
technischen dinge wie strom fährt zur
zubereiten können
das ist ein gewisser fortschritt und
auch die grünen machen fortschritte
sie entwickeln historisches bewusstsein
und sie fordern jetzt habe ich gehört
eine umfassende aufarbeitung
konstruktion kommission
es sollen nämlich geklärt werden die
rolle der afd bei der machtergreifung 33
die rolle der afg bei den nsu morgen
2000 bis 2011 wir wurden ja 13 gegründet
der waren schon immer an allem schuld
und das heißt jetzt auch es dürfe keine
äquidistanz zu linke bzw afd herrschen
und wenn sie mal im bundestag sind auf
der pläne
schauen sie mal in den fraktionssaal der
linken da hängt ein plakat riesengroß
mit einem zitat des ex-vorsitzenden
bisky wir stellen die systemfrage
die linke will das system der brd
abschaffen die afd will in wirklichkeit
den grundsätzen dieses systems endlich
wieder uneingeschränkt geltung
verschaffen wir bewahren den rechtsstaat
und von wegen den rechtsstaat
verächtlich machen haben sie von ramelow
snow plan gehört als er noch davon
ausging dass die cdu gegen ihn stimmt
und sich nicht enthielt da sollte er
gewählt werden indem einfach vier
abgeordnete zur toilette gehen so war es
durch diskutiert das schreibt er selbst
auf facebook plan war dass in der
dritten abstimmung vier unionspolitiker
sich aufs klo begeben ich vermute das
sogenannte range lglo der stefan stefan
bestätigt mir dass ich sehe dass gerade
hast du diese tradition auch im
bundestag eingeführt seid ihr so
zusammengekommen
gut erklären dass später damit also
rammel klo auf jeden fall gewählt wird
und er selber habe das schon mehrfach
praktiziert sehr beruhigend
toilettengang stadt wahlgang die
demokratie wird bei der linken
anscheinend neuerdings auf der toilette
verteidigt so wird demokratie
verächtlich gemacht meine damen und
herren von der linken
aber liegt in thüringen die cdu
abgeordnete ja nicht mehr dem gewissen
verpflichtet sondern nur noch könig bodo
dem ersten sie wollen jetzt durch
enthaltung ihn für ein jahr zum
ministerpräsidenten machen dafür schenkt
er der cdu ein jahr vergessen beim
wähler über die schmähliche
rückgratlosigkeit der union die cdu und
fdp abgeordneten die kemmerich gewählt
hatten die wurden ja von ihrer
parteiführung mit dem politischen tode
bedroht wenn politische todes der
parteiausschluss man stelle sich das vor
cdu-abgeordnete sie plötzlich arbeiten
müssten
daraufhin haben die natürlich dass
zurückgezogen jetzt wollen wir doch mal
sehen ob gegen die ramelow unterstützt
ähnlich brachial vorgegangen wird ich
bin gespannt weil damen und herren und
was das thema ausgrenzung angeht wer die
afg abgeordneten zu abgeordneten zweiter
klasse macht der macht in wahrheit ihre
wähler zu wählern zweiter klasse der
wird unter der hand ein zwei klassen
wahlrecht eingeführt das sind die
stimmen die nicht gelten sollen in der
demokratie
sie sollen unwirksam sein das ist der
angriffe auf die demokratie in diesem
land das ist ein putsch gegen den einzig
legitimen souverän gegen das fehlende
deutsche volk meine damen und herren
dagegen müssen wir uns verwandt die
beschädigen die demokratie die der afg
seit drei jahren einen bundestagsvize
präsidentin vergeigen die zu später
stunde im bundestag gesetzentwürfe
verabschieden während die
beschlussfähigkeit mangels abgeordneten
gar nicht mehr gegeben ist wollen wir
dass gemäß geschäftsordnung überprüft
sehen behauptet eine claudia roth
einfach dreist es seien genug
abgeordnete da okay man bei ihr ist man
sich nicht ganz sicher ob sie nicht
meinte richtig gezählt zu haben dass die
90 leute 355 waren und die afg kann in
berlin seit monaten keinen parteitag
durchführen weil linksextremisten die
räumlichkeiten abfackeln wollen wo sind
denn da die ritter der demokratie wo ist
die demokratische ferne ist wenn die afd
nicht zu talk sendungen eingeladen wird
während baerbock und habeck sicher
förmlich unter mieten können nein meine
damen und herren wenn die altparteien
eine brandmauer ein ziehen zwischen sich
und der afd
sitzen die altparteien auf der seite der
brandstifter zusammen in erfurt metro
vierten mörder partei nein meine damen
und herren liebe freunde nonkonformist
gegen den strom schwimmen und für seine
meinung einstehen standhaft zu bleiben
sich nicht einschüchtern lassen das sind
die charakterzüge die einem höheren
idealismus entsprechen
das waren 13 30 jahren so und das ist
auch heute noch so
auch wenn man dafür sozial geächtet wird
ausgegrenzt wird aus kinos und
restaurants heraus geworfen wird wenn
den kindern der kita und schulplatz
verweigert wird der arbeitsplatz in
gefahr gerät und anschläge auf wohnung
autoleben drohen das auf sich zu nehmen
und dem druck nicht zu weichen das
braucht neben mut einen ausgeprägten
gerechtigkeitssinn der sich nicht
einfach wegdrücken lässt weil es
bequemer ist den mund zu halten und
diese rückgrat qualitäten die einen uns
alle die wir heute hier erschienen sind
in der afg
sie haben angst vor uns nicht weil wir
die demokratie gefährden das glauben sie
selbst nicht sondern weil der frische
wind den wir bringen sie von ihren
posten zu werden droht sie sehen ihre
felle davon schwimmen geraten in panik
wir hatten unser bildungssystem zerstört
und deutschland zum pisa user gemacht
wer hat den sender nonsens zum
familienfeindlichen leitgedanken erhoben
wer hat milliarden an steuergeldern für
bankenrettung und transferunion
veruntreut wer hat eine kopflose
energiewende losgetreten wer will jetzt
unsere diese abschaffen wer hat die
grenzen geöffnet und sich islamistische
gefährder ins land gelassen wer ist
dafür verantwortlich dass im internet
jetzt zensiert wird und die freie
meinungsäußerung unterdrückt wird nein
es ist ganz klar warum diese kampagnen
gegen die afd gefahren werden und man
sogar darauf verzichtet lieber ein
ganzes bundesland wie thüringen zu
regieren wenn man nur die afd die aus
jetzt hier ausgrenzen kann
denn im gegensatz ion ahl parteien haben
wir für die drängenden probleme des
landes die klaren für den bürger
verständlichen antworten das macht sie
für die anderen parteien die afg so
gefährlich da man ihr nicht argumentativ
beikommen kann werden wir über als nazis
diffamiert kein mittel ist dazu schäbig
die straßenschläger der antifa werden
von der leine gelassen ich sage den
altparteien geht es nur noch darum ihre
freunde vor unliebsamer konkurrenz zu
schützen das ist hier in diesem staat
los denn denn als die afg in den
bundestag einzog da war allenthalben zu
hören man werde uns jetzt argumentativ
stellen davon ist nichts mehr übrig
geblieben offenbar sind unsere argumente
so gut dass es nun wieder gilt der afg
kein podium zu bieten und eben alle als
nazis zu diffamieren ein nazi was ist
denn das eigentlich ist das ein alter
weiser mann ist ein nazi jemand der eine
andere meinung als anetta kahane hat ist
ein nazi jemand der nicht land und geld
deutschlands an illegale immigranten
verschenken will die tausende kilometer
durch sichere drittstaaten gereist sind
und nicht schutzbedürftig sind sind das
alles nazis
diese altparteien leben in einem
universum intellektueller
vollverschleierung und die betragen die
verrohung der sprache wenn ein märz über
uns sagt wenn ich was beitragen kann
dass dieses gesindel wieder verschwindet
dann mache ich das das sind die hetzer
laschet will uns bis aufs messer
bekämpft
elmar brok nennt die werte union ein
krebsgeschwür wanderwitz twittert über
einen kollegen ein kranker maßmann
zerfressen von hass und dummheit die afg
und der kollege sind giftiger abschaum
das ist die sprache des hasses das sind
die wahren hetzer
das muss man hier ganz klar gestellt
werden nicht die afg ist es sondern
diese leute die uns ohne ende
diffamieren
und dann hören wir immer man wolle sich
entschieden gegen hass und hetze
einsetzen
wie also kein heute schon einmal mehr
keine tagesthemen keine nachrichten und
kommentare von ard und zdf chefredakteur
soll der linke flügel des bundestags
kein rederecht mehr erhalten
nein meine damen und herren wir sind
hier heute zu aschermittwoch
zusammengekommen
ich muss ihnen sagen man wünscht ja
niemanden glühende kohlen aufs haupt die
werden ja nun auch mangelware greta sein
dank die kohlen
sie könnten sich auch auf einigen
schuldigen scheitern häufen
die müssten eigentlich asche auf ihr
haupt streuen und denke nicht mit lob
und preisen vom ausland überhäuft sollte
die person von dannen gehen sondern in
sack und asche die deutschland und die
alte cdu von adenauer kohl und strauß
bis zur unkenntlichkeit zerstört hat
derzeit sehen wir wie die jetzt noch
mögliche schwarz gelb blaue mehrheit im
bundestag in thüringen tabuisiert und
verfemt wird für das hauptziel der
diktatur geschulten kanzlerin
denn ihr ziel deutschland mit der
zerstörten union bereit zu machen für
eine mehrheit der neuen linken
einheitsfront dieses ziel ist nahe liebe
freunde der aschermittwoch gemahnt und
dem ein ende zu machen
die erfurter demokratie verhinderung
darf nicht schule machen diese
demokratie zerstörung durch die
altparteien dazu muss es ein gegenmodell
geben eine alternative eine alternative
für deutschland deshalb mut und glück
auf deutschland mut und glück auf du
land der bayern setze ein zeichen für
die beendigung der herrschaft des
unrechts setzte ein zeichen an den iden
des märz setzt das erwachen in gang
befreit das land liebe freunde ich danke
euch
gottfried kurioser ist der
innenpolitische sprecher der fdp
bundestagsfraktion er weist eine
mitschuld der fdp an der dem anschlag in
hanauer klar von sich der fall werde
instrumentalisiert von der zitat
altparteien hetze und den altparteien
hetzern wir wollen dazu ein paar stimmen
hören von der reifte wir haben ja grad
herrn curio gehört der hatte mit
schuljahr fdp
bei dem anschlag in hanau klar von sich
weist aber haben wir nicht problem mit
rechter gewalt in deutschland nach dem
angriff auf die synagoge und dem morden
und weiter ludger auch das sehen aber in
der afg leute wie man das war referenzen
kann also da fällt mir jegliche vorstand
das gibt der umfrage dass 60 prozent der
deutschen sagen die afg hat insofern
eine mitschuld als dass sie das
politische klima schafft für solche
taten die dran fischen die wahrheit zu
sorgen
da reden wir dann so einen scheiß was
ist normal
man kann das eher verfolgen wir sind an
die blöd wir können wir haben ja die
ganze scheiße metalle
wir haben ein bisschen mehr krebsen mehr
verstand wir sehen das ja wir sind schon
ich bin mein leben lang politisch jetzt
gibt es aber in der afc eine
innerparteiliche diskussion und geo
paczkowski der berliner fraktionschef
sagt die grenze nach rechts außen muss
jetzt klare gezogen werden
gehen sie damit über die schon zustimmen
ist bei den grün ging es da genauso los
das war alkalische ohne ende und das
wird sich in der fliege genauso es
kristallisieren dass die normalen
bleiben und die aber müssen geht aus
kannst gar nie sein wo würden sie dann
die grenze ziehen nach rechtsaußen nach
rechts aus in welche richtung die na ja
was aussagen angeht was politik angeht
naja ich kann das jetzt nicht mit
einzelnen rosa ich kann dir die sonne
was da heute gesagt haben ja gut das ist
ja ich will extrem aber das mittel
wieder patzelts gewinn berlin das
vollkommen in ordnung der mann also ich
kann da nur mich anschließen und härter
würden sie ausschließen kann ich
ausschließen aber der muss alter der
muss der sehr muss sich mäßigen
das geht so ne aber er hat im publikum
an sich gezogen durch seine äußerungen
das ist das dann stehen sie für den
gemäßigten flügel würde ich jetzt mal
raus hören
deswegen die abschlussfrage zum cdu
machtkampf der macht bringt sich ein
herr merz in stellung als möglicher cdu
chef und kanzler wer würde der ihnen
politische heimat bieten wenn es ein
thema im prinzip ja aber man muss ja
schon mal abwarten wie das hier geht
dieses hatten das ist sowas hat ze die
ordner nie gegeben
ja soweit ein paar stimmen hier beim
politischen aschermittwoch der asd in
osterhofen und wir geben damit zurück
nach bonn